hi this is an experiment i bought myself
a selfie stick
uh with a tripod
and uh just to vary things a bit i'm
going to shoot some videos here both
inside the house and possibly again
outside
and uh hoping that this works uh i'm
gonna talk today uh i mean okay
in the winter as i've said before
uh largely because my wife likes to come
down here because it's sunny and stuff
we come down here for four months of the
year
we like coming down here uh we like
coming to california to the states
we like the people here are very
friendly the community where we live our
neighbors are very helpful
and we love it and of course being down
here i've been watching on tv
the various uh uh debates of the uh
presidential hopefuls or at least the
people who are involved in the both the
republican uh primaries and the
democratic party primary so i want to
comment a little bit you know uh i do
want to occasionally make this sort of
occasional
um political
video so what are my thoughts on these
various candidates
starting with the well let's start with
the democrats because only there's only
two of them
i think that bernie sanders
is a very irresponsible and very
simplistic
and i think it would be a very bad thing
if he were selected as um
you know if he were voted in as
president of the united states
and the reason i say that is because to
him
you know everything is the fault of wall
street everything is the fault of big
business if only we strengthened the
unions but if you really listen to what
he's saying there's so much
inconsistency the inconsistency i
watched him the other night and he was
saying you know everyone in the states
should have access to university
education free of charge
uh
maybe
uh maybe but if you listen to him he
basically has nothing but
scorn for
factory jobs like he says people
shouldn't have to work in a factory job
or he said something to the effect of
it's not the greatest job in the world
or on two or three occasions he implied
that a factory job is not a great job
and therefore the solution is that
everybody should get a university
education and then they wouldn't work in
factories
well the fact the matter is that a
probably only 30 or 40 percent of jobs
require a university education even
though parents would all like their kids
to go to university
a lot of what kids do at university is
largely a waste of time there have been
studies to show that don't improve their
ability to communicate to use the
language they really don't learn an
awful lot especially in the humanities
which is a large part of why people go
to university so
uh i mean i think that universities
should be heavily subsidized but i don't
think they should be free of charge and
i don't think it's a panacea
and so i think just insofar as and i
don't and i think a lot of people having
worked not as a factory worker but i've
spent time working in factories and many
people actually enjoy those jobs because
that is their social nexus that's where
they meet people they do things that are
meaningful they become very expert in
certain jobs and that becomes their life
they're just as proud of that as he is
of being a politician
so that sense of fire sanders i didn't
appreciate his whole approach to that
and his somewhat demagogic approach to
to uh
social justice as he calls it
with um uh
hillary i just think she's been involved
i mean again i'm against this whole
dynastic approach
you know bill clinton was there so now
we're going to get hillary clinton
and i just find like even in terms of
her final comments she twice i think
made reference to the lgbt community i
have nothing against the lgbt community
but that's not an awful lot of people
that is it might be a bit of a litmus
test in terms of the
tolerance of a society but she seemed to
emphasize her support for certain
interest groups the unions the lgbt
community and so forth and i felt that
that again was unnecessarily sort of uh
narrowing her appeal and made me feel a
little bit suspicious of just how
um
you know how much of a of a person with
empathy for all different points of view
she is
moving on to the republicans uh in no
particular order i think ben carson it's
absolutely extraordinary i mean he says
things that are completely off the wall
uh he ended his comments the other night
by quoting stalin
as uh ascribing to him a comment that
stalin never made you know so i don't
take him very seriously
um rubio and his final comment
said you know uh
everything is bad we're losing our jobs
uh wrong is right ryan right is wrong
which is all unnecessarily alarmist and
then he said that we need to recognize
that the rights that we enjoy in the
constitution don't come from the
president they come from our creator
well first of all nobody suggests i
haven't heard people say that the rights
in the american constitution come from
the president
um that's a bit of a straw man
on the other hand
for someone who wants to be president of
the united states to me as a canadian
to suggest that the laws or the rights
that americans enjoy
that they enjoy them because of the
creator
that's like sharia law that's like
laws are created by god
and it's not people who make gods
make laws
my belief is all of our rights and laws
uh are basically
arrangements that we agree upon as a
society this is how we want to lead our
lives this is what we uh obligate people
to do this is what we allow people to do
because we think this is a nice way to
uh
organize society it's not something that
is is
natural law god-given law the only thing
natural is our
general inclination to like reciprocity
and i think there's a bunch of reasons
why
reciprocity makes a lot of sense do unto
others as you would do have them do unto
you jeb bush brought his brother out the
other day i mean the more i see his
brother involved in supporting jeb bush
and jeb bush seems to also be involved
in this petty squabbling between him and
ted cruz and
trump and so forth that i would not vote
for jeb bush
a because he's would be the third bush
member to be prime minister bear in mind
i'm not american so i have no right to
vote so i'm only commenting as a foreign
observer and not impressed with bush
uh who else do we got cruz he just comes
across to me as being very petty and
sort of uh
sniping back and forth i mean there's
nothing statesmanlike about the man he
doesn't represent any any sense of boy i
would really like him as a leader at
least that's how i react to him
uh and i have hadn't haven't really
heard much other than he's gonna be
tough on immigration gonna be tough on
that tough on this he to me he doesn't
stand for anything so i wouldn't vote
for him
uh trump
uh who's very popular
i can't understand it i think he is the
the most irresponsible of all those
people
um
he never misses an opportunity to to to
burn bridges to aggravate people to uh
you know a couple of recent examples
like the pope makes a comment about
trump saying he's not a christian to my
mind the pope shouldn't make that
comment he has no right to interfere
in the electoral process in the united
states in fact are i'm not catholic but
the pope i think wanders a lot into
political areas where he doesn't belong
but that's a whole other issue he has
many positive
attributes and he is the leader of
50 of all the christians in the world
being the catholics and so trump though
could have easily said you know it's
unfortunate that he said that uh but
don't inflame the situation similarly i
saw him today in a video clip uh saying
that uh people should boycott apple
because apple won't cooperate with the
fbi on this issue of of uh giving access
to uh to uh the iphone used by a
terrorist well in fact if you read about
it the situation is quite complicated
there are very good reasons for apple to
refuse fbi access the fbi access to the
phone there may be other reasons why
they should but it's complicated it's
not something that should be decided by
someone who aspires to be president
whipping people up by saying well
boycott
apple what's boycotting apple in other
words we will
basically use strong arm methods
strong our methods to achieve what we
want we will bully apple basically is
what he's saying and that's kind of the
approach to take that he takes to trade
relations
i mean the united states the united
states exists
because it has relations with other
countries china japan mexico and to just
constantly
say these people are ripping us off as
he says uh i i keep on expecting to hear
that canada is ripping them off too
it's so unnecessarily inflammatory
and i don't see the purpose and he's
saying
uh promising to do things that he won't
be able to do
at the very least he won't be able to do
them by himself and if he's burning
bridges with everyone else who's he
going to do them with how is he going to
sit down with mexico and arrive at some
deal that's going to help control the
flow of immigrants similarly with this
whole muslim thing we'll ban all muslims
whatever he says until they're all
checked i mean there's one and a half
billion muslims in the world they're not
going to go away
there are
people in the muslim world who say we
have to
we have to look at the quran and we have
to look at the historical context in
which certain things were written and
maybe update ourselves in terms of what
makes sense today today when there are
so many muslims living amongst
non-muslims
and so there are those people and and i
think it makes much more sense to work
with those kinds of muslims so that the
muslim world doesn't consider the
western world as their enemy now that
might be unrealistic but i also think
it's unrealistic to make all those
people your enemy
um
who else who did i leave out
kasich kasich
i am very impressed with governor kasich
he has a presence
he has empathy with people he for
example
talked every time i've heard him speak
he's talked about people with mental
illness and there are a lot more people
with mental illness i believe in the
united states than
the
the numbers are larger than say the lgbt
community so if we hear hillary always
talking about the lgbt community i'm
much more impressed with kasich who
talks about the mentally ill because
they don't
lobby and have parades and and
you know they aren't the squeaky wheel
but there's a lot a large number of them
and there are serious problems and it's
related to
the very high incarceration rate in the
united states drug addiction crime and
so many other things so i'm very
impressed with the degree of empathy
even though i'm not a religious person
and he bases
a lot of his
of how he conducts himself including in
his in his uh public persona on his
personal beliefs but he doesn't force
these beliefs on others and so if i were
voting
in the united states
i would vote for
kasich and he is the only one of all
those people
who who who impresses me and i'm not
saying that because in canada somehow we
have better politicians i'm not at all
impressed with our new prime minister
and that could be a whole separate rant
and i didn't like our previous prime
minister either
but i just thought it would be fun to
throw some comments out there about the
uh the primary race in the united states
because it's quite topical so i look
forward to being bombarded by negative
comments
from my listeners
thank you for listening bye for now
you